[Music]  the weekend jets back to LA to celebrate  girlfriends Selena Gomez's birthday the  27 year old singer was in Paris to  perform at Lollapalooza on Saturday  Selena's actual birthday but by Sunday  he was back in the City of Angels where  he was spotted out on a lunch date with  his leading lady the bad liar singer  looked cool and casual in a loose white  top and matching drawstring pants the  weekend was also dressed down opting for  a navy tracksuit  [Music]  on Saturdays Selena ring in her  milestone birthday with friends the 25  year old songstress took to Instagram  with several photos from her intimate  celebration which was complete with  birthday cakes and blue and white  balloons she thanked everyone for their  birthday love with this pic writing I  couldn't be more blessed a lot of you  don't realize how much you mean to me I  love you think 25 is going to be epic  EXO  [Music]  you